hey mike well remember the other night  jason tatum's two and a half year old  son deuce was the fan  of the game when we had the celtics on  sunday deuce was in the virtual crowd  and apparently loved getting to see his  daddy play  uh look at him there i thought that the  late night tip  might be past deuce's bedtime tonight  but jason told me before the game that  deuce was going to try to hang in there  for a quarter  and he did uh which is probably a little  longer than mark  jackson did well what happened to mark  had to beat the traffic  you know what though when you think  about  boston fandom look at there's so many  people that stayed around in the virtual  to watch the end of an absolute blowout  what fans they have